[Applaudissements]
car la nuit pourquoi j'ai choisi de vous
parler de résilience parce que d'abord
ce mot me plaît dans résilience
j'entends résistance et puis j'en ai été
le témoin actif de cette résilience aux
îles marquises
plus précisément à nuku hiva où je vis
depuis 1981 alors qu'est ce que c'est la
résilience
physiquement c'est l'aptitude d'un corps
à résister à un choc pour un peuple
c'est l'aptitude c'est là une
communautés résilientes
elle apprend à s'épanouir à se
développer malgré le traumatisme ou la
catastrophe
quand je suis arrivé aux marquises
les premières fois que j'ai visité les
sites culturels historiques
il était à l'abandon j'étais révoltée
mais avant que je vous passe de ce long
processus pour moi et pour ce réveil
identitaire marquisien il ya une
question qui m'a interpellé c'est celle
de mes frères qui vit à tahiti qui m'a
dit pourquoi les marquisiens sont ils si
fier et là je lui ai dit mais ils sont
si fiers parce que ils reviennent de
loin
ils ont failli disparaître complètement
c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui soit fier
donc je vais juste vous rappeler faire
un bref historique des trois dates qui
ont marqué les marquises en termes de
dépopulation en 1774 quand le capitaine
james cook fait un bref voyage autour
des marquises rien qu'on dénombre on le
nombre de pirogues doubles dans l'ebit
qu'il a pu plonger
ils estiment la population entre 80 et
100 mille habitants un siècle plus tard
en 1842
il n'en reste plus que vingt mille 20
mille parce que il y a eu tous ces
contacts avec les baleiniers laissant
aller les boucaniers
et enfin tous ceux qui se sont qui ont
touché les marquises avec leur lot de
maladies dame d'opium et en 1926 il ne
reste plus que 2094 habitants pour
l'ensemble des marquises c'était les
derniers survivants ceux qui avaient
résisté
donc quand on voit cette dépopulation se
dit comment ils ont réussi à arriver
jusque-là en souvent mon mari lucien
kimitete qui était un grand leader
culturelles et politiques avaient
l'habitude de citer cet exemple en 1912
quand les grands chefs marquisien se
réunissent à tard ou ata et se pose
cette terrible question pourquoi mourons
nous et il arrive à cette conclusion
nous mourrons parce que nous n'en sont
plus
parce que nous ne dont sont plus est il
se passe des années des années jusqu'à
ce qu'on 72 a lieu le premier festival
des arts du pacifique
créé par les premiers pays indépendant
du pacifique
donc on à fidji eux aussi s'interrogent
sur leur culture
eux aussi ont besoin de se retrouver et
donc ce festival un succès énorme et il
se produit toujours du puits 72 tous les
quatre ans dans les trois aires
culturelles mélanésienne polynésienne et
micronésienne dont 85
quand ça a lieu à tahiti une délégation
marquisienne ci invite et
le président de notre association
culturelle d'otites équivoque aux sons
inspirent ils voient ils voient cette ce
festival comme une formidable
opportunité de se retrouver de partager
la culture marquisienne entre pour les
marquisiens par les marquisiens et donc
avec d'autres meneurs culturel ils vont
sillonner toutes les vallées pour
demander à participer à ce mata mata va
ça veut dire les yeux va ouvrir donc
l'éveil des marquises mata va ôter
rhinois énorme et ça n'a pas été facile
parce qu' il fallait convaincre les
anciens de transmettre de transmettre
les danses les chants les savoir-faire
et eux répondaient à nos meneurs
culturel pourquoi voulez-vous faire ça
ce sont des rites païens
vous allez pas remettre des rites païens
pourquoi voulez-vous réhabiliter les
sites
nous les avons abandonné parce que nous
ne voulons plus de ces rites païens et à
force de persuasion
le premier festival a lieu
awa peau en 1987 alors pour la petite
anecdote nous pour yves associeront
comme qui va avoir comme fatu hiva
3 il seulement avec guapo évidemment
quatre îles sur six se retrouve à ce
festival et la délégation de nuku hiva
et hiva avait que seulement 30 personnes
25 sommes pratiquement tous des artisans
chacun avec une sculpture dans la main
et cinq femmes est là pour nous notre
délégation de nuku hiva
on voit les autres en costume
traditionnel et on a la honte de notre
vie et ses deux premiers chocs culturels
pour nous et là on parce qu'en fait
notre président le président de notre
association n'y croyez pas pour lui
c'était une réunion de motu jaca donc
de notre association et on n'avait pas
préparé de champ on n'avait pas préparé
de danse donc la veille de l'ouverture
et nous fait chanter et il va acheter un
pad ou pour tout le monde pour toutes
les filles et donc on nous mener les
cinq filles d'ailleurs j'ai une amie
dans la salle qui était là aussi
et on est cinq filles avec des paris ou
des tee-shirts et les hommes sont en
pantalon et on est en tricot et les
autres sont en costume traditionnel et
donc lors de notre dernière réunion
nous insistons nous insistons tellement
auprès du comité organisateur ont dix
ans le prochain matin 20 c'est chez nous
c'est à nuku hiva
or dans la légende marquisienne
normalement c'était hiva oa mais nous
étions tellement blessé de ne pas avoir
participé comme il faut que s'était il
fallait que ce soit notre revanche
culturelle et donc en 89
nous organisons le second matin var à
nuku hiva
et puis on a tiré les leçons
à chaque fois c'est à dire que la
première fois c'est sur un terrain de
foot et la deuxième fois on a dit non
on fera ça sur un site fera ça sur un
site culturel
donc on a dès qu'on est rentré on a
commencé à travailler et à réhabiliter
un dpp donc une plate forme
traditionnelle
honte aux voix qui est le lieu de
festivités pour tous les toutes les
marquises et on appuie donc réalisé ce
matin val il a lieu maintenant tous les
deux ans sur les petites îles et tous
les quatre ans sur les grandes îles donc
cette année en décembre 2019 aura lieu
le matin bart de wever sur le thème
comment la culture comme on a la culture
peut-elle contribuer à préserver et
protéger l'environnement à ce matin à
vannes s'ajoutent également d'autres
aspects bien sûr d'autres réveil c'est
le tatouage le tatouage avait été
interdit aux marquises par un code qui
s'appelait le code d'ordi lyon en 1863
donc il se passe plus d'un siècle plus
personne ce tattoo et puis là avec ce
matin va il ya un réveil et là les
jeunes commencent à se tatouer plus les
jeunes la preuve c'est que mon mari en
il n'était pas tatoués il s'est tatoué
quand 95 donc c'est pour vous dire que
leur ancienne génération ne se tatouent
n'est pas parce que c'était mal vue mal
interprété et surtout l'église était
contre le tatouage donc de plus en plus
les jeunes se tatouent le corps mais
aussi le visage pour affirmer leur
culture leur âme culturel retrouver et
même ceux qui sont pas marquisien comme
moi nous aussi nous taton
pourquoi parce que moi par exemple
personnellement j'ai trouvé mes racines
là bas en épousant un marquisien j'ai
trouvé mes racines j'ai ça m'a pris 15
ans quand même
j'ai commencé par le tatouage sur le
pied et aujourd'hui je le porte sur la
main parce qu'elle est avec moi il est
avec moi tout le temps mon mari m'a
montré le chemin lui qui s'est tellement
battu pour sa culture marquisienne il
faut savoir que quand il était jeune il
avait honte de dire qu'il était
marquisien parce que quand on venait à
tahiti les marques qu'ils n'étaient pas
bien considérés
c'était des retours payne c'était des
gens qui n'avaient pas de terre c'est
des gens qui vivaient dans des quartiers
et puis il était mal considérés je vais
même vous dire comme je suis parti aux
marquises ma grand mère paternelle mains
dit surtout tu reviens pas avec un
marquisien parce qu'ils avaient des a
priori sur sur cette culture sur sur les
marquisiens et puis puis c'était un
archipels éloignés perdu aujourd'hui
avec ce réveil identitaire j'entends les
jeunes me dire oui ça fait 32 ans donc
ils ont grandi avec ce réveil
identitaire il pense que ça a toujours
été la queue
il ya toujours eu les danses les chants
que les sites qui aujourd'hui enfin qui
hier étaient abandonnés sont aujourd'hui
tous réhabilité parce qu'à chaque matin
va on essaye de réhabiliter le site de
le rénover de l'entretenir régulièrement
pour l'ensemble des marquises et chaque
fois on gagne un site supplémentaire à
chaque matin là donc ils pensent que ça
a toujours été là ils savent pas que les
anciens ont eu honte ils savent pas que
ils ont été obligés de partir à un
moment de leur archipel parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de travail aux marquises
qu'il fallait venir à tahiti
c'est pour ça qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de
marquise et imprécis et puis ils n'ont
pas et n'ont pas connu tout ça donc
n'ont pas connu la dépopulation
aujourd'hui les marquisiens les jeunes
marquisiens sont fiers
ça c'est la réponse à mon frère oui ils
sont fiers et ils ont raison d'être
fiers
conscient de tout ça aussi nous avons eu
beaucoup de scientifiques qui sont venus
nous voir qui ont fait des études et on
sont arrivés aux conclusions que comme
c'était justement un archipels éloignés
il y avait un fort taux d'endémisme en
termes de nature
donc du coup on s'était dit que c'était
important aussi de préserver la nature
et c'est pour ça que nous avons donc
demandé à inscrire notre patrimoine
notre part dans notre archipel où
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité parce
que pour nous la nature et la culture
sont indissociables donc il était temps
de mettre cette nature en avant et puis
il faut arrêter de parler des marquises
c'est bien on parle de lui très longs
prés on parle de gauguin quand on parle
des marquises on évoque brel et gauguin
vous savez les marquisiens il aimerait
bien qu'on parle aussi de leur nature et
de leur culture et donc c'est une façon
de d'avoir cette reconnaissance
alors il ya lors des divers séminaires
que nous avons eues sur l'unesco où 42
sites ont été choisis identifié parce
qu'ils étaient importants pour nous il
l'avait
ils sont les témoins du passé mais aussi
aujourd'hui les témoins du présent on
vit avec leur manne leur pouvoir c'est
le pouvoir des pierres et aussi de la
nature qui les entoure puisque autour de
ces sites à chaque fois vous voyez des
banians magnifique on a un très beau à
ratifier ou qu'il ya 600 ans et donc
c'est une manière voilà de reconnaître
cette cette nature et cette culture
exceptionnelle
je vais aussi faire un petit aparté en
disant que effectivement choix qu'on a
tous mon message ce serait de dire qu'on
a tous une pierre a mené à l'édifice de
la vie on n'est pas là par hasard
je n'ai pas été aux marquises par hasard
on m'y a envoyé l'univers m'a envoyé
j'ai trouvé mes racines là bas j'espère
que vous trouverez aussi vos racines où
que vous soyez les anciens avaient
l'habitude de dire que quand on passe
une montagne à chaque fois qu'on va dans
une autre vallée il faut prévenir les
tupuna les anciens qu'on arrive et donc
on doit pousser un cri et quand on s'en
va on doit aussi aider prévenir qu'on
120 et ce cri c'est tanawa et tout est
acquis et toi tu as qui est tous au kaki
mais c'est cotonou
[Applaudissements]